less than 48 hours after we talked to
her at the Golden Globes Elvis's only
daughter Lisa Marie Presley is rushed to
the hospital this is Entertainment
Tonight she was so happy to honor her
father and celebrate the film and Austin
Butler's performance now here is the
latest on her condition
[Music]
hey Lisa how are you
his four-year-old who seemed to struggle
a bit Tuesday night at the Golden Globes
was rushed to the ER this morning after
suffering Cardiac Arrest full arrest
EMTs responded to her home outside La
where they performed CPR and reportedly
administered epinephrine a stimulant
usually used when CPR and defibrillators
cannot get a pulse sheriffs tell ET they
were able to get a pulse and transport
her to the hospital the cause of Lisa
Marie's heart trouble is unknown but
back in 2018 the star revealed her past
battle with drug addiction I was not
happy and by the way the struggle in
addiction for me started in you know 45
years old I've come a long way
everyone's it's I mean I have a
therapist and she was like you're a
miracle you really are she's like I
don't know you're still alive I'm not
perfect my father wasn't perfect no
one's perfect cut to Tuesday night she
was
she was emotion after
other one best actor for l
hey Priscilla I love you forever it was
mind-blowing truly mind-blowing I I had
to take like five days to process it